the only thing scarier than being
haunted by a ghost is getting sued and
you may not believe in ghosts but that
doesn't mean that they don't show up in
lawsuits
[Applause]
because telling ghost stories isn't just
something that you do around a campfire
or as an overused plot device in horror
movies like once I met this guy who knew
this guy who knew this guy who knew this
guy who knew this guy who knew in fact
ghosts have actually repeatedly been
involved in litigation we would have to
perform
asuance
and when it comes to the Paranormal in
court judges don't simply say ghosts
aren't real and get that [ __ ] out of my
courtroom judges have repeatedly treated
Spirits with a veneer of seriousness in
both civil and criminal cases and on
occasion poltergeists have even helped
establish legal precedent that we still
teach law students to this day so let's
start with the ghost who testified from
the dead to convict her own murderer in
July 1897 Edward Trout's shoe was
convicted of first-degree murder By A
Greenbrier County West Virginia jury in
the Strangling death of his wife zona's
shoe what makes this gruesome murder so
notable is the evidence that sealed Mr
Shoes fate came from a most surprising
Source the ghost of his murdered wife
this was the first end to date only
instance in the US history that
testimony of a ghost has been admitted
as evidence to obtain a conviction so
how did this ghost help convict her own
killer well it's quite the story on the
morning of January 23 1897 the 23 year
old Zona shoe was discovered by an
errand boy sent to the house by trout
shoe the boy found her at the foot of
the stairs face down dead her head
cocked to one side by the time the
coroner arrived trout had moved his
wife's body to their bed where he had
dressed her in a scarf and high neck's
gown trout was sobbing uncontrollably
and showed signs of distress whenever
the coroner attempted to examine the
body now out of respect for The Grieving
spouse the coroner stopped his cursory
examination and then wrote in his report
that Zona died of about Everlasting
faint or heart attack at zona's wake the
next day attendance noticed more odd
behavior from trout when the casket was
opened for viewing trout immediately
covered zona's neck with a scarf and
propped her head with a pillow and
blanket a trout also put on a display of
inconsolable grief blocking mourners
from getting close enough to look at the
body then one month later while zona's
mother Lay It wide awake at night zona's
Spirit appeared before her mother to
reveal a shocking truth that Zona was
murdered and trout was her killer sona's
mother then went to the local prosecutor
to reveal what she had learned from her
daughter's ghost over a period of four
nights zona's ghost reportedly appeared
and gave a chilling account of her
murder Zona Spirit revealed the trout
had a his history of physically abusing
her when trout became enraged one night
that Zona didn't serve meat for dinner
he grabbed his wife by the throat
crushed her windpipe and snapped her
neck between the first and second
vertebrae after hearing this the
prosecutor went to the corner to ask
what he had observed about zona's neck
when the coroner revealed the husband
had prevented him from examining the
neck the body was exhumed and a second
autopsy was performed they found bruises
on zona's neck in the shape of fingers a
crushed windpipe and her neck broken
between the first and second vertebrae
matching the mother's account from the
daughter's ghost and in the course of
investigating the prosecutor discovered
that Shu was not who he seemed Edward
trout shoe was actually Erasmus shoe a
blacksmith from a neighboring County she
also had a history of violence and was
married twice before his first wife got
a divorce after enduring physical abuse
while his second wife died under
mysterious circumstances after eight
months of marriage but after trout was
charged with a murder there were real
concerns about securing the conviction
while zona's neck was broken and there
were hand marks there wasn't much hard
evidence linking trout to the crime the
prosecutor was reluct into subpoena
zona's mother fearing her ghost story
would actually damage the case but
instead of discrediting the witness it
appears that it actually bolstered the
prosecution's case here's an excerpt
from the remarkable exchange Mrs heaster
are you positively sure that these
visits are not for dreams yes sir it was
not a dream I don't dream when I'm wide
awake to be sure and I know I saw her
right there with me are you not
considerably superstitious no sir I'm
not I was never that way before and am
not now now I would like to say if I
could to get you to say that these were
four dreams and not four Visions or
appearances of your daughter in Flesh
and Blood I'm not going to say that for
I'm not going to lie so Pro tip for all
you aspiring trial lawyers out there
don't tell the witness you're
cross-examining what you want them to
admit because they're probably not going
to do that ultimately the jury convicted
trout with just over an hour of
deliberation he was sentenced to life
which ended up only being three years
when he died in prison but that brings
us to the medium who faced an extra
large copyright lawsuit after claiming
that Mark Twain's ghost wrote her book
because at the turn of the 20th century
America was in the midst of a craze of
spiritualism during this time the
practice of holding seances and seeking
guidance through mediums became
increasingly popular in the United
States so in St Louis medium Emily Grant
Hutchings claimed that her new book jab
Heron subtitled a novel written from the
Ouija board was actually authored by
Mark Twain's ghost as revealed to her by
the Ouija board many Americans bought
the book believing Hutchings claims
among those skeptical of the book's
ghostly Origins Mark Twain's estate and
Twain's publisher who were so offended
by the claims they went straight to
court seeking to block publication and
have every copy of the book destroyed it
all started in September 1917 when the
book got national attention following a
scathing review from The New York Times
panning the book as quote a feeble
attempted imitation of Twain's humor the
reviewer cast out on its ghostly Origins
by noting the recent trend of dead
authors allegedly writing books through
Ouija boards quote if this is the best
that Mark Twain can do by Reaching
Across the barrier the army of admirers
that his Works have won for him will all
hope that he will Hereafter respect
boundary in June 1918 Mark Twain's
estate through his daughter Clara
Clemens and Twain's publisher Harper and
brothers went to the U.S Supreme Court
to file an extra large copyright suit
against the medium and her publisher
Mitchell Kennerly the complaint alleged
to Harper Brothers had held the
exclusive right to Twain's stories for
17 years and Hutchings and Mitchell
Kennerly were infringing on that right
the complaint asserts that quote Jeff
Herron is far below the grade of
anything Mark Twain wrote while alive
and the circulation of the book would
harm his reputation the complaint
further alleged that Hutchings
approached Harper's with a book in 1916
but Twain's publisher refused to publish
it on quote the ground that it didn't
emanate from Mark Twain and had no
literary merit for Relief plaintiffs
requested that the Supreme Court block
publication of the book have all copies
destroyed and require full accounting of
all illegally earned profits however the
plaintiff's victory was by no means
assured to establish copyright
infringement they'd have to prove
definitively that a ghost spoke through
a Ouija board which was no easy task and
as the New York Times reported at the
time quote there is of course ground for
doubt whether testimony transmitted
through a Ouija board will be accepted
the court may consider it incompetent
irrelevant and immaterial and it's kind
of amazing the kind of hedging of bets
that the New York Times was doing with
the word May in that particular sentence
but anyway the plaintiffs here put forth
a clever two-step legal strategy to
Corner the defendants on the one hand if
Twain's ghost did actually write the
book The defendants have committed
copyright infringement and must return
all profits made to Twain's estate and
publisher on the other hand the mediums
could avoid a copyright Claim by simply
admitting the Twain's ghost didn't
actually write the book which would
expose them as Liars so stuck between
the rock of massive copyright exposure
and the hard place of admitting to be
frauds the mediums agreed to Halt
publication in the book and remove all
copies from stores the copyright trial
of the century would never come to pass
but Hutchings would continue to insist
that she was telling the truth until her
death in 1960 though Mark Twain famously
quipped if you tell the truth you don't
have to remember anything so whether
Hutchings was a liar with a great memory
or an unjustly mocked profit I suppose
we'll never know
but that takes us to a couple of ghostly
cases coming out of Texas they say that
everything's bigger in Texas but you
know what else is bigger in Texas cases
where people took Financial advice from
ghosts only to claim fraud when the
advice didn't pan out you know that Old
Chestnut because in the early 1900s
Texas Courts addressed the issue of
ghostly misrepresentation in both civil
and criminal context in the case of
virtual versus hermsmeyer Bell Burchell
claimed ghosts told her that there was
substantial oil under her land I drink
your milkshake believing this to be true
h.c hermesmeyer invested ten thousand
dollars about 175 000 in today's dollars
into virtual's Oil Company when no oil
was found hermesmeyer sued to recover
his investment arguing that virtual's
claim constituted a fraudulent
misrepresentation of fact but the Texas
court of appeals disagreed ruling the
ghosts cannot form the basis of a
fraudulent misrepresentation because the
existence or non-existence of ghosts is
uncertain and a matter of belief not
fact and a similar result occurred in
the criminal case of nurse versus State
Gym nurse a self-described spiritualist
claimed that he could speak to ghosts
who told him a large amount of money was
buried under the property of one Mr
Alexander a heavily invested in gold
which I've buried in several different
locations around colony
or have I after someone working on Mr
Alexander's home found money buried by
The house's Foundation nurse advised
Alexander to re-berry the money
immediately because otherwise the
spirits would vanish it all a nurse
allegedly returned later to dig up the
money nurse was swiftly arrested and
convicted of the crime of swindling the
early 20th century term for fraud now
the state argued nurse was a charlatan
who fraudulently induced Alexander to
part with his money by falsely claiming
he could talk to ghosts but like virtual
the court of appeals threw out the
conviction on the grounds that whether
or not nurse can talk to ghosts is an
unknowable fact that cannot serve as the
basis for a fraud claim quote there is
no evidence in regard to the matter one
way or the other that is as to whether
or not appellant conversed with the
spirits or called them up and tested
their veracity ultimately the court
concluded that Alexander was neither
deceived nor misled because the alleged
fraudulent claims that money was buried
under Alexander's house was actually
true and since the underlying claim was
true whether nurse could talk to ghosts
was legally irrelevant and nurse's
swindling conviction and was reversed
but that takes it to the house that was
haunted as a matter of law now one of my
favorite Halloween Traditions growing up
was watching The Simpsons Treehouse of
Horror episodes I still remember the
very first Treehouse segment bad dream
house where the Simpsons family is
horrified to discover the mansion that
they just bought is haunted and actively
trying to murder them now obviously this
is just a silly cartoon and no one would
ever try to actually get out of a real
estate purchase because the seller
didn't mention that the house was
haunted right well this actually
happened and it was successful in this
opinion which is taught in every Law
School in the Country Wasn't handed down
a hundred years ago during America's
spiritualism craze but in 1991 less than
one year after The Simpsons episode
aired yet another example of The
Simpsons predicting the future as you
know we've inherited quite a budget
crunch from president Trump so here's
the story of America's first legally
haunted house Jeffrey and Patricia
stampovsky were a New York City couple
who decided to leave behind the big city
and move slightly Upstate to the Village
of niacc New York while looking for a
new home the stambofsky's fell in love
with an 8 bedroom 4.5 bath Victorian
Mansion occupied by by George and Helen
Ackley and their four kids Mr stanbowsky
agreed to buy the property for 650 000
with a 32 500 down payment so what's the
problem here well the sellers neglected
to mention that the house had a
decades-long reputation for being
haunted a reputation that the athletes
themselves helped cultivate by talking
it up in the local and national press in
the 1977 Readers Digest article our
haunted house on the Hudson the Ackles
recounted the family's many ghost
interactions in the home most notably
husband George claims he saw a pair of
disembodied moccasin clad feet walk up
the stairs while Helen claims that she
saw a man in a powdered wig and
Revolutionary War attire the house was
even a feature on a walking tour of
Nyack and periodically attracted
paranormal enthusiasts now after
learning about this previously
undisclosed ghostly History Mr
stanbowsky filed suit-seeking rescission
of the real estate contract but the
trial court dismissed stampovsky's
claims citing caveat mtor caveat empor
Latin 4 let the buyer beware imposes a
duty on a buyer to reasonably examine
the fitness and value of property before
purchase and under this principle a
buyer is barred from rescinding a
contract on the basis of defects that
would have been discovered through a
reasonable investigation but stampovsky
appealed this decision and the court of
appeals reversed the trial court
reasoning that because the sellers
themselves were the source of the home's
haunted reputation and this fact that
materially impaired the value of the
property could not easily be discovered
by even a diligent buyer the failure to
disclose was grounds to cancel the
agreement quote whether the source of
the spectral Apparition seen by
defendant seller are parapsychic or
psychogenic having reported their
presence in both a national publication
Reader's Digest and the local press in
1977 and 1982 respectively defendant is
a stopped to deny their existence and as
a matter of law the house is haunted
so what happened next well the
stambofskis were able to back out of the
deal but don't worry the athletes had no
problem reselling the house since then
the house has changed hands multiple
times being most recently sold in March
2021 for 1.8 million dollars and in 2002
New York replaced caveat mtor with an
affirmative duty to disclose sellers are
now required to fill out a standard form
disclosure statement containing 48
affirmative representations about the
condition of the property though sadly
zero disclosures about ghosts and there
haven't been any hauntings since the
ackleys left which some paranormal
investigators attributed to the ghost
being bored of the new owners now if you
like ghost law and want more scary law
stories you should listen to John
grisham's new legal thriller the judges
list on today's sponsor audible it's all
about a judge who was also a serial
killer and uses the law against his
investigators because the killer who
knows how to manipulate the legal system
is the scariest killer of all
I use Audible almost every day it's by
far the best source of audio
entertainment I listen to audiobooks
when I'm running cleaning up or when I'm
supposed to be listening to friends and
loved ones audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
all in one place if you try to listen to
everything it would take you three
centuries as an audible member you'll
get one credit every month that you can
use on any title in the entire premium
catalog that includes basically every
bestseller new release or Memoir these
titles are yours to keep forever in your
audible library and then you also get
access to their popular plus catalog
which is filled with thousands and
thousands of audiobooks original
entertainment guided Fitness and
meditation sleep tracks and other shows
all are included with your membership no
credits needed now right now audible's
running a special promo new audible
members get a free one-month trial you
can try it out and see why I love
audible all you have to do is go to
audible.com legaleagle or click on the
link that's on screen right now or down
in the description so right now for a
limited time get a free one month trial
of audible by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court